HAD A SHOUT OUT FOR ELON MUSK
AND SPACE X, WHICH PRIVATELY
FINANCED FALCON ROCKET PROGRAM.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
NANCY PELOSI SAYS IT IS GOOD TO
HAVE TENSION AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, AND IN THAT CASE, THINGS
ARE REALLY GREAT FOR DEMOCRATS
ENTERING THE MIDTERM ELECTION
SEASON.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY LOOKS
AT THE WIDE DIVISIONS AMONG
DEMOCRATS, WHICH NOT EVERYONE IN
THE PARTY SEES AS A GOOD THING.
>> IS BEING A MODERATE DEMOCRAT
DIVIDES MIDTERMS A LIABILITY?
NEW YORK MAYOR BILL de BLASIO
JUST CALLED HIS GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO A MODERATE AS AN INSULT.
CALIFORNIA'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
DECLINING TO ENDORSE ITS
LONG-TIME
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN, PAVING
THE WAY FOR A MORE LIBERAL
CHALLENGER.
>> THANK YOU!
SPEAK IT IN AN ILLINOIS RACE,
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS JUST
ENDORSED A PROGRESSIVE
PRIMARY CHALLENGER, DAN
LIPINSKI, WHO WAS MORE MODERATE.
>> THERE ARE THOSE WHO WANT TO
HAVE A TEA PARTY OF THE LEFT IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, TO MATCH
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT IS HAPPENED
TO THE REPUBLICANS.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE A BIG TENT
PARTY.
SPEAK ABOUT STRATEGISTS AREN'T
SO SURE THE MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD
LEADS BACK TO A HOUSE MAJORITY.
>> THE GREAT THING ABOUT THE
ENTHUSIASM THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS SEEING FROM FOLKS WHO
ARE FURTHER TO THE LEFT AND MORE
PROGRESSIVE THAN THE MODERATES,
IS THAT IT IS BRINGING MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE PARTY, IT IS
INCREASING THE ENTHUSIASM.
>> SOME DEMOCRATS ARE WARNING
AGAINST EXTREMES.
>> WE NEED PRO-LIFE DEMOCRATS.
WE NEED DEMOCRATS WHO AREN'T AS
STRONG ON GUN CONTROL SOME OF US
ARE.
>> DNC CHAIR TOM PEREZ WHO
RECENTLY KNOCKED THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE
FOR PUTTING OUT OPPOSITION
RESEARCH ON ONE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY CANDIDATE, TELLS FOXLEY
INFIGHTING IS OKAY.
>> DO WE HAVE SPIRITED
PRIMARIES?
SURE WE DO.
BUT WE HAD SPIRITED PRIMARIES IN
VIRGINIA LAST YEAR AND PEOPLE
CAME AROUND.
>> DON'T CONCERNS FROM THE TOP
DEMOCRAT ON THE HOUSE EITHER.
>> IT IS THE MOST EXHILARATING
THRILL TO BE A LEADER AND A
PARTY THAT HAS THAT KIND OF
DIVERSITY OF OPINION,
CREATIVE TENSION.
>> A MANTRA EMBRACED BY THE
SENATE DEMOCRAT WHO JUST SERVED
ON A NATIONAL TICKET THAT LOST.
>> WE ARE A PARTY THAT HAS
TOLERATED SOME PRETTY WIDE TO
DIVERSITY OF OPINIONS FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> AND THERE ARE LIMITS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S POTENTIAL
PROGRESSIVE TURN.
>> IS THERE A DANGER IN THE
PARTY GOING TOO FAR TO THE LEFT
DO YOU THINK?
>> THAT WON'T HAPPEN IN
WEST VIRGINIA.
>> BUT JUST ABOUT EVERYWHERE
ELSE, SO FAR THIS CYCLE IT SEEMS
THAT THE ONE LAWMAKER WHOSE
ENDORSEMENT GETS THE DEMOCRATIC
BASE, THE MOST FIRED UP AS
BERNIE SANDERS.
WHAT IS NOT CLEAR YET IS WHETHER
OR NOT INDEPENDENCE OR
UNDECIDEDS ARE READY TO FOLLOW